[Music]  you can't just show up here with no  warning what's wrong does something  happen  yes  nicholas has come to live with me and  he's improving but he's a little fragile  the way he came to see me you're blaming  me for what happened  he's different from the others what  makes you say that why don't you answer  me i do answer you the look in his eye  is disturbing she wants to turn us  against one another  back then there's so much joy in our  family i feel like a complete failure  i'm like this it's your fault what have  i done what's my fault haven't i always  done everything for you i have the right  to reinvent my life it is my life  [Music]  everything okay at home  yeah  everything's fine  [Music]  you